no currents report we have part 2 of the
button hey what's up I'm Nick hi how you
doing I'm sorry that's me to talk about
this big again are you bringing the lego
dude back baby give me one more chance
I think so yeah it give a coherence
maybe hearing us he'd be talking to us
I'm here today nothing much I'm just I'm
just taking a gap year from college
right now so I just woke up and clean my
room stuff oh yeah yeah like this right
before that smashed down don't even know
how much in your nineteen saw the way
she looked around like cops were coming
in like that was bait it's not that he's
young it's the fact that he's oblivious
to what he's singing the effect it has
on it just like the last episode when he
said the Lego stuff and the man who
Orion do you think that between two
episodes gonna catch a clue age Monica
at least age take him more than that
even when I was 18 I knew what my AI was
still I was already like we're not
talking about you it's all about him I
know I know that goes god bless his
gender so ginger
I'm 26 you got kids no not yet I got
kids what wasn't a reaction after her
keys you know what I mean you got keys
something came out you know okay well I
militia you know ready banks let's BJ so
at least you had around I'm gonna let
you run a bit I know but hey hey you got
a round though you know appreciate it
iris pat on the back slap on it that's
how I'm gonna get rejected and you cute
by imma let you on the back cuz it's not
working for me you got to do what you
got to do when you got to do it let me
release you you not me nobody you see me
here nice heroes okay I got kids
hello oh hi Holly I am six seven Mike
doesn't he just look like he defends the
most important library in the world just
when he walk there you're like oh yeah
that's all are you yeah it's pressure
are you nervous
I am excited nervous man it look like
they put the head of a Buddhist monk on
lurch doesn't it to lunch and family the
button oh so own G reference my body's
not gonna catch that no okay what do you
do for fun i smugly that's about what I
do for fun I mean I have kids so you
know I'm pretty much a homey mom right
now so kicking it's not really my forte
I feel bad you know what I think for the
dating scene it's a lot harder for women
and kids in a man to have kids and I'm
not saying it's hard for men it's not
I'm not saying it's not hard for a man
to have kids but perception the men have
out of a woman taking care of kids and a
perception of a woman that the woman has
of a man taking care of his kids is not
the same the thing that happened is that
I'm gonna be really honest right now
when a man what a man what a man sees a
woman and she had like a bunch of kids
she's a single mother and she is
independent I the man I think most men
are gonna see the reason why she's
single mother I'll tell you the truth
because I've had this situation happen
to me a few times the truth is and this
is an honest-to-god truth going to
dating you don't want to be encumbered
right away with huge commitments when I
am dating a single mother I'm
understanding the fact that I will soon
be entering potentially a child's life
which means that I have an extra layer
of responsibility because now if I leave
I'm not just leaving the mother I'm also
leaving the child
yeah and that no man wants to feel
burdened with that responsibility or
hurt that child so for me I was always
cutting so I'm like I was told woman I
don't want to meet your kid yet until
I'm really sure like I waited a long
time before that was a possibility so
that's why people are reluctant because
it's just extra pressure when a woman
sees a man with his daughters to her
that's endearing that's nice
that's a man taking care of business
well because they see I make a good
provider
I can see that for their own children
make the car a cloud will pop I'm not
ready to be like a stepdad or nothing
like that yeah most people had that
reaction it's like that's a lot of
responsibility she's like I got Keith
I'm the strong man it doesn't matter
that's our perception it's not what the
girl's gonna impose on us it's how we
perceive the situation I'm young
I'm sorry hello I'm James investor how
tolerant oh why is he looking at him
like she gonna even look like a snack
there is something man Chris yo listen
judge on older women when they look at
you Baylor's do they just ready ain't
got no time to waste the older women are
like yo I did all the bull that I had to
do before yeah
how tall are you I'm 510 I'm talking
about your point man the most gangster
thing an older woman ever said to me was
I was like yo listen when we go on the
date I'll pay for the food I said that
to her I said I'll pay for the food you
don't know expectation
she said yeah yes we are I am six seven
Wow yeah may ask how you earn five four
by four we cool
No oh I gotta release some tension
because I was so awkward holding too
late oh that's awkward
that's awkward to late imagine telling
someone you're gonna old man too late
I felt like I walked in on my
grandparents but both my grandparents
are already dead so that I'm just
confused and I'm cringing because I'm
like house as possible but then I'm also
like yo I didn't want to see this but
I'm glad you're alive but I'm like this
shouldn't be real you know how the floor
is not me
[Music]
- wait I'm sorry that she's ready to
kill this Nia she gonna slap that button
before him yeah yeah he's too timid he's
not ready even though she can watch you
saw that listen here's someone lasts but
their teeth are closed that's not a good
sign this robot mentions the fact that
he likes thick girls twice awful
do you like fried chicken and watermelon
aim orange I'm sorry
yeah that's purple drink oh my mom deep
is Rob back do you know what do you
think of it maybe think of like you know
when you're at a party just chilling as
like a black person present and then
someone's just like trying to show off
their black lingo teas like oh yes I
just learned this new dance called a hit
the fans oh that's pretty uh well you
know a person that's healthy
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a real [ __ ] moment right there
that's when you know the answer is no
but this guy's got enough compassion in
him to not say it but if it was me I'd
be like ah but she cute just say it just
say it
she doesn't have to be thick not every
girl you're gonna meet is thick those
guys gotta grab his balls he's too
passive
[Music]
[Laughter]
my name's Thurston okay these guys Louie
they're made for each other
Thurston and Cosmo this guy looks like
it belongs on her shirt Thurston and
Cosmo
he's thirsting for Cosmo that's for sure
what's your name who Jesse Jesse I'm
Kayden
I've never wanted to use the pronouns
leave them there until right now I don't
know there's something about what I look
at this person I don't know what's going
on but that bless her soul what you
don't want to get canceled i'ma leave
you alone in your hurry okay how old are
you there's more sound than words that
coming out of this girl is like arias
relationship seven or eight months ago
now probably 2013 with staying power
that's I'm sorry you've been a great
date you made a great day goodbye
this is brutal I'm an [ __ ] hello hi
mom come in with a winter cub - in
California what is this maybe cold maybe
he got the a/c on or maybe man's not hot
Skippy deep so this thing can talk to us
yeah can you give us a prompt honestly
not for not for a long time I'm like
waiting for it to hit me and so many
moments have passed that it hasn't I'm
like am i able to cry anymore you know
what anyway I hope that cry comes for
you in a good base I'm waiting um no
sparks I knew this is gonna be harder
than tinder it's great to meet you happy
birthday happy birthday thank you so
much
see you at the next one well to be fair
if I was just straight dude and they
brought up some random guy up I'm gonna
hit the button soon as possible I don't
think they're all sweet no if I was I
would also just be looking together
don't think they are they all dabble
double dip exactly
now how do you feel about people who
double dip literally yeah like a little
dipping sauce and then they dip and it
and it depends how you do it okay so you
have a problem bisexual people I'm
Carter nice to me nice to be here all
right cool
what's poppin I was good not much just
worked all day I'm gonna meet you yeah I
work to just give people pastries and
[ __ ] make coffee I'm a barista
Yeah right about you I'm a server at all
car dude live you get free breadsticks
though you don't get free breadsticks
[Music]
you look like you want you faking it
what you didn't see the ending free
breadsticks though you don't get free
breadsticks okay that's
you're out Oh howl it I'll let you get
like free breadsticks
oh that's lit man that's real cool all
right so you like work at the Olive
Garden
man they got like smashing pizza because
he did it yeah to story with creeping on
oh yeah you know honestly anyone if
you're into me I'm into you imagine red
flash imagine like someone was coming to
try to love you and you like I love
anybody even you this is like gross are
you into me that's all that matters
hi I'm Carter I'm Jamie nice to meet you
how's your day going it's going honestly
really great yeah yeah that's good now
you should girl the girl got her
seduction skills yeah yeah she turn it
all the way up yeah even me I just
noticed a bike my pants have been coming
down a little bit I was near like the
way she's making the other person is
really into her she's really engaged
because you notice most people when
they're gonna hit the button
they preemptively give it off by being
disinterested and that's what she's
doing right now yeah this girl's falling
for it what do you do for your hobbies I
like to paint [ __ ] man I'm going to
school right now for graphic design
because I'm trying to like make a brand
for myself maybe like 2000s cartoon
watch like Cartoon Network and oh yeah
I'm trying to get all of those
characters tattooed on me bro
oh really do have any tattoos at all
yeah yeah I've got like a clown right oh
I like but these are all sticking pokes
my friend doesn't if you don't know yeah
I'm sorry
like these are like beautiful sticker
right I'm like serious about color
blocking on my body so I have like I'm
sorry you can't fish me bro oh I guess
you won't be hitting the fans now she
can't fish yeah make it seem like this
was all interested put her guard down
yeah I don't see the player she play as
she plays yeah what's up yeah you know
we gonna come out of this you know we're
gonna come out of this st. eggsy
[Music]
in general like I can see us being like
really good friends but like I can't
like see like a romantic relationship in
it okay I love your lashes thank you you
look this girl is amazing she's amazing
at getting people to fall for her while
guarding her own feelings at what she's
thinking
it's impressive like this guy's all
inter he's not even but I can tell you
she's not engine welcome to customer
service yes yes and to be honest with
you every time I've gone to the Korean
store to get some food I don't know how
they feel about me either but the
customer service is amazing yeah me too
what yeah I don't know what's your
experience I know it's a TD it for me it
feels like everything's like moving
through my head a million miles an hour
yeah the Baris like things easily
because I think that I'm saying things
wrong like like he was opening up about
something that he'd you deal with hey
Dee Dee's really up and she's just like
I just caused you a lot of trauma yeah
he's really cute but like I don't want
to talk about like my ATD and stuff but
like someone else is this like made me
kind of hi I'm good how are you my name
is Mikey at least he didn't come with a
jacket this time but he should have
dropped a fanny pack
he should have come with a jacket you
know he's not gonna stay long
love your glasses of your eyes oh but
like Ron Burgundy style I'm kind of I
like playing a funk and jazz bands this
is her first time her body languages
looked at any difference so I'm assuming
that's a good thing because there's got
such a good poker face I can't tell but
this is the first time she's leaning
back and she's talking every other time
she was like leaning for a really
serious relationship three years ago and
I lived with my ex and there was really
bad breakup and I know that like having
a separate myself from my entire friend
group and like kind of restart yeah yeah
mine was like two and half months ago oh
[ __ ] yeah really but we just make
weren't right for each other we - [ __ ]
where's joseline yeah what stop suing
off chop suey
do ya I'm talking about I'm just hungry
right now yeah can we have music
imagine if you were a kid and this was
what they gave you an example of what
robots would look like in the future
one should be like you meant technology
we got record players that just put a
little needle and they played beautiful
music and in the future robots are like
all right preach any thoughts on the but
what do you think sorry I just think
this shows terrible it's a terrible idea
first show the button adds no value it's
what I said in the last video it should
be what I'll say again this video but
it's great cringe material so I'm
grateful because you guys got to cringe
with us that's about it
otherwise so that's pretty much it I got
no real notes for this there's no notes
to have it's not a real thing
I did laughter you ever tried to
eliminate that woman and then the button
changed and he had to sit there
awkwardly with her and then she got him
bad yeah that's like breaking up with a
girl and having to wait with her before
the uber comes yeah and the Hoover is
like 15 minutes away yeah and then the
uber cancels and you got to get another
uber and you both got to sit there
awkwardly but you know it's over yeah
and then she looks at the guy she was
like man I'm dropping a fire mixtape
right so anyways that's it for today's
video let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear you
[Music]
the first off before we start I want to
give you a gift I had a gift for you
Abba all right you know I I know so I
got you this
oh it's a bit tricky it's a bit weird no
it's not like that it's right here I get
annoying repackage I just wrote this
[ __ ] apart crystal ball just one I was
gonna use some credit you have a crystal
ball you'd be like well I got a crystal
ball you have a ball even when I grabbed
into the bottom like bonuses because I
know it was just related to this is a
good inside joke when I saw these on
Amazon I was like